the school of the Art Institute of
Chicago has just announced that it will
rescind Kanye West's honorary degree in
light of the offensive comments that
Kanye has been making about Jews now I'm
obviously not defending any of the
things that Kanye has said about the
Nazis or the Jews or anything like that
but it just seems to me
I don't know if you guys are history
Buffs or not
it just seems to me that if the goal
here is to get Kanye to stop identifying
with Hitler
rejecting him from art school is
probably not the best way to accomplish
that goal but people don't study history
and Karl Marx wrong as he was got at
least one thing right all great world
historical facts and personages occur as
it were twice the first time is tragedy
the second as far as I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on Friday is from Christoph
Rodriguez who says name what team
Brittany Greiner plays for without
looking it up beforehand yeah no one can
do it this is why of all the reporting
around Brittany Greiner and Russia and
this whole episode The the part that I
found most absurd that the least
credible
was when they would say Brittany Greiner
WNBA star
WNBA star gets arrested in Russia there
is Russia is holding a double there is
no such thing as a WNBA star no one has
ever watched a game of the WNBA in its
entirety and anyone who's told you that
he has is lying
okay it's not speaking of girly things
what are you gonna get your girlfriend
and your wife for Christmas you got to
check out Pajamagram right now head on
over to pajamagram.com tell them that
Michael sent you women love getting new
pajamas at Christmas time Pajamagram
makes it really really easy for us men
this year I cannot wait to give sweet
little Elise a set of pajamas from their
naturally nude line even more alluring
than lingerie the texture and feel of
these pajamas is so silky and smooth
that both you and your wife will love
them if you have no idea what to get
your girlfriend or wife this year trust
me she wants these pajamas but you need
to order today because last year they
sold out before Christmas because
they're extremely popular because
they're phenomenally high quality order
today and Pajamagram will include a free
naturally nude nighty with your order
that is 75 savings on their best selling
holiday gift Pajamagram offers free gift
packaging so your present comes ready to
to put under the tree go to
pajamagram.com right now and order the
naturally nude pajamas that is
pajamagram.com for naturally nude
pajamas do not forget to tell them
Michael sent you
speaking of history repeating itself
and also speaking of people taking
things away from others you remember Sam
Brinton
Sam Brinton is a controversial Joe Biden
appointee he's in charge of nuclear
waste at the department of energy and
he's the bald guy with the mustache who
is not only a sexually deviant sort of
person
which I don't I don't want to you know
spread rumors or tell Tales out of
school or gossip about anybody but this
is not some secret with Sam Britton he's
made it a big part of his public Persona
he photographs himself wearing all sorts
of weird costumes leading grown men
around on leashes and the men are
dressed up like little puppies he gives
lectures and conferences on all this
kind of weird sexually deviant stuff he
wears dresses and high heels and
lipstick and he's just he's pretty out
there well he he was accused a couple of
weeks ago of stealing a woman's luggage
at an airport
and he initially denied it but then he
kind of came out and he said he did it
but he was just tired and he didn't mean
to and well now another arrest warrant
has been issued for Sam Brinton for a
second alleged theft at an airport a
felony arrest warrant has been issued
for Brenton for Grand Larceny with a
value between 1200 and 5 000 for
allegedly stealing luggage from Harry
Reid international airport so the first
time it didn't take place in Nevada it
took place in Minnesota he flew into
Minneapolis with American Airlines and
he traveled without a checked bag so it
shows you he had no reason to be at the
baggage claim after the flight and then
authorities called him that same day and
asked him if he took anything that
didn't belong to him and he said no not
that I know of and later he said okay
yeah maybe you know look if I took the
wrong bag I'm happy to return it but
this was really weird he said that the
other person's clothes whose bag it was
were not in the bag he said
I don't have any clothes for another
individual
that was my clothes when I opened the
bag but obviously it was it was this
other woman's bag and and apparently on
the security footage you can tell he he
took her tag off of the bag and put it
into his pocket and and so then he said
no it's maybe it's this other one's bag
with my clothes were in it so it's
really you got to ask yourself what is
this guy do
did he steal her clothing did he why did
he did he want her clothing did he did
he just want to steal the bag then he
took this other bag here and and again
according to the footage they didn't
initially couldn't identify him even
though he was wearing this gay pride
nuclear shirt so it was apparently like
a rainbow nuclear reactor or something
like that on the trip they couldn't make
him out who he was until the first news
story came up and then they said wait a
second I think that's the same guy there
and apparently he was exhibiting all
this kind of odd behavior he uh let's
see here we are he he was he he went to
the Carousel and took a bag off and then
kind of looked around suspiciously and
put the bag back on and then you know a
little bit later he took the bag off
again looked around suspiciously so uh
we we have an article here at Daily wire
it says police disclose how they caught
alleged Biden Administration luggage
Thief Sam Brinton and uh
this is a quote from investigators in
Las Vegas they say
Brinton demonstrated several signs of
abnormal behavior
and it goes on to say while taking the
victim's luggage which accused suspects
typically give off
I think you could have stopped at the
first part of that sentence
Brinton demonstrated several signs of
abnormal behavior gee you don't say the
man with the mustache who wears lipstick
he's got totally shave dead we're
stiletto heels mini skirts leads grown
men around in leather costumes on a
leash he he was behaving in a bit of an
eccentric and abnormal way gosh you
don't say you know it's always the ones
you most expect
people like to think it's always the
ones you least expect no no often it's
the ones you most expect
because our perception and our faculties
of Reason are actually pretty good
guides to things and in fact Prejudice
with pre-judgment looking at a situation
and just quickly having a gut reaction
is not all the time but a lot of the
time a pretty good guide to things this
is why Edmund Burke the conservative
philosopher you know great conservative
philosopher uh so valued Prejudice
because we we don't have a time to in
every single situation in our lives come
up with a perfectly rationalist kind of
explanation and treaty and argument for
what we're about to do we just kind of
go on our gut we go on hunches and we we
refer uh to the wisdom of the ages and
we defer to tradition into the past and
we we can trust our gut all right and
that obviously would be the case with
this guy and this guy
Sam Brinton is obviously deeply troubled
and should not be handling anything
involving the America's nuclear program
and should seek a lot of counseling and
maybe should be in a padded cell I don't
know but he certainly should not be in a
position of authority and I I have a
great deal of sympathy for him because I
look at a guy like Sam Brenton who
is so troubled and I think
what if earlier on in his life
someone anyone had just told him no
now we live in a culture where if a
five-year-old comes to school and says
hey hey I'm a girl today they say well
Johnny I guess we're gonna have to get
you on hormone therapy yeah you do that
or what if earlier on in this life when
when this guy was exhibiting abnormal
deviant Behavior
any adult just said hey don't do that
that's wrong if you do that kind of
deviant Behavior that's going to lead
you to more deviant behavior and then
you're going to have a bad life and
you're gonna have all sorts of problems
so don't do that actually you should
look it's a crazy world it's very
diverse we're very eccentric but best as
you can be normal
just be normal I keep coming back to
this theme on the show because I think
it's a pretty good guide for politics
and I think that a lot of the
conservative
political programs should come down to
these two words be normal it's okay to
be normal the left likes to suppress
normality and disparage normality and
and likes to subvert everything and
likes to elevate the abnormal and the
transgressive above all the good normal
stuff but it's okay just be normal guys
it's okay and if people had done that
earlier on in this guy's life maybe he
wouldn't end up as a cross-dressing
puppy fetishist baggage Thief stealing
women's jewelry and clothing at the
airport maybe maybe he would have gotten
take taken the off ramp at some point
down that highway to bizarre
transgressive behavior you look at the
Biden Administration I mean it's filled
with all this kind of bizarre imagery
and often occult symbolism there's that
other guy who was the deputy monkeypox
Czar for Biden who wears overt satanic
symbols where is that the leather
harness and the pentagram and takes and
he too now this isn't secret I'm not
divulging his private sins the guy takes
glossy photos of it puts it out there
into the world
and this stuff is on the rise Satanism
overt Satanism is on the rise if you go
to the Illinois state capitol right now
you know it's it's Advent we're
preparing for Christmas time
we we look around we see Christmas trees
in the Public Square well if you go to
the Illinois State Capitol
you will see a crash the nativity scene
you will see a menorah
which
you know Hanukkah is a minor feast day
it's not it's a it's not a major Jewish
holiday and and so not to to equate
Hanukkah with Christmas on as a matter
of importance for the respective
religions I think is a little silly
anyway but okay you see the menorah most
people don't have a problem with Menorah
and then the third thing you will see is
a Satanist display it's a serpent
with little apples on top of a
leather-bound copy of Nicholas
copernicus's uh on the revolution of the
celestial spheres which is especially
strange because Copernicus was a
Catholic Canon and and possibly a
Catholic priest so I the satanists as
you might expect are kind of confused
with what they're doing but uh at the
center of it you've got this this
Serpent and it's there because the
satanists are claiming that if the
Christians get their nativity scene and
the Jews get their Menara then the
satanists
have the right as a matter of religious
freedom to put up a serpent at Christmas
time and the thing is most people know
that this is wrong and we should not be
expected to tolerate this
but very few people including
conservatives very few people can
explain exactly why the satanists have
no right to a serpent at the Illinois
state capitol at Christmas time the
satanists have no right as a matter of
religious freedom
to put up a serpent display at the
Illinois state capitol they have no
right to engage in their public Antics
anywhere as a matter of fact
I made this point over the weekend on
social media
and the libs went crazy and the squishes
went crazy and even a number of
conservatives asked Michael come aren't
you abandoning the First Amendment
doesn't the First Amendment and the
right to Religious Freedom protects the
satanists from there no it doesn't
of course it doesn't as a matter of
History it obviously doesn't
we had established churches throughout
this country the First Amendment did not
prohibit established churches at the
state level
until well into American history because
of
certain
legal and judicial
errors in interpretation and Implement
implementation of certain laws but
furthermore we had blasphemy laws on the
books
for for a lot of American history
you could be punished by the state if
you blasphemed God
so obviously it was not the view of the
founding fathers or the framers of the
Constitution or most of the Great Men
Who Built our country that the First
Amendment or the Constitution protects
the sacred right of satanists or
anything like that in fact
the very notion of religious freedom
precludes protections for satanists the
reason is that religion is not just
anything you believe about anything I
know colloquially that's how we refer to
religion that's not what religion is
religion has a real definition okay
the religion is the moral virtue by
which a person is disposed to render to
God the service and worship that God
deserves that's what religion is
okay religion is a kind of a Justice
through which and by which we give God
what God deserves
so it's not just any belief you have
about anything and so in this country we
have a tradition of religious freedom
which means that we are relatively quite
tolerant about how people worship and
serve God we might think that one
religious group is not worshiping God in
quite the right way you know the the
episcopalians might say those methodists
they are not rendering service and
worship to God as they ought but we have
a broad kind of Toleration
for for the different groups who
sincerely think that they're worshiping
God in the way that that he deserves
even if they're a little bit wrong about
it
the satanists do not do that they
singularly do not do that they hate God
or they deny God's existence
and there's not it's a little bit of a
blurry line between those two things but
whatever satanists believe
they certainly do not believe that they
are worshiping God and serving God
whatever satanists believe either their
edgy online atheists or they are
explicitly worshiping the prince of lies
that the chief Rebel and first rebel
against God's plan either way they can't
have religious freedom because they're
not religious they're irreligious and
religion and irreligion are not the same
thing we have become even the
conservatives have become so
relativistic in recent years
well this actually is at the heart of
that argument over drag queen Story Hour
when David French who was a sort of
conservative writer now he's a liberal
writer for the Atlantic David French
came out and he said drag queen Story
Hour is a Blessing of Liberty and if we
ban drag queen's Story Hour from public
spaces while by golly the libs might ban
church services I don't know Christian
Services from public spaces so who's to
say one man's drag queen Story Hour is
another man's preaching of the Gospel no
of course not they're not the same thing
they're different things and if you
can't discern between those two things
then you don't have any faculties of
reason you can't govern yourself
no religion and irreligion are not the
same thing and this is not just some
crazy far-right Theocratic view this was
commonly understood by everybody in the
country certainly by the people who
framed the Constitution certainly by the
people who built our country until like
five minutes ago okay it's it's not a
fringe view to say no the satanists
don't ever write to to put up serpents
and statues of demons in public spaces
there is a reason that that hasn't
happened in American history until very
recently and it's because
the the Liberals have become more
radical and the conservatives have
failed to conserve a damn thing okay and
we and now we we can't even articulate
what the Constitution actually says we
don't even know we ourselves we even we
the conservatives don't really know what
religious freedom means anymore
I promise you guys it does not mean
putting up statues of demons and
serpents in state capitals okay that is
not that is not it when you are doing
that and when you were pretending that
that is some sacred right uh enshrined
in our political order you have lost the
plot
speaking of
things that are not very religious lying
that's not very religious that's exactly
what Twitter has been doing we've been
reporting on the Twitter files releases
that have come out uh Elon Musk and the
journalists Matt taibi and Barry Weiss
have been sort of slowly dripping out
the Twitter file story in part because
there's so many documents to go through
they can't do it all at once so the
update here
is that is that Twitter lied Twitter
lied a lot
and Twitter lied about Shadow Banning
and Twitter lied about the way that it
was treating conservatives so what what
did we just find out in the new Twitter
release after Banning Trump
after taking this unprecedented step to
ban a sitting head of state sitting dual
elected president of the United States
Twitter then immediately starts talking
about how it can use its newly newly
taken power
to ban other presidents in the future
so they start talking about how
the new Administration could be
suspended by Twitter but they will not
be unless it's absolutely necessary but
you see this from company messages and
memos and slack channels then the
executives admit that they didn't ban
Trump
over any particular tweet
so this was something that was so clear
when they banned the duly elected
sitting president is
what did he won even if he had violated
some rule it shouldn't be
I don't think that a handful of woke
people in Silicon Valley ought to be
able to control the Public Square such
that they can kick out the president of
the United States clearly something's
gone wrong then but they they admit no
no it wasn't that he did anything in
particular they said they removed him
over the quote context surrounding
actions by Trump and his supporters
quote over the course of the election
and frankly the last four plus years
so what did they do they wanted to ban
him
and then they just made up an excuse
but it was it was about the four years
then
they
they have to come up with some scheme as
to how they ban people otherwise it's
just total Caprice
so
we see before January 6th Twitter was a
unique mix of automated rules-based
enforcement and more subjective
moderation by senior executives
this according to Matt diabe is very
Weiss reported The Firm had a vast array
of tools for manipulating visibility
most all of which were thrown at Trump
and others before January 6th so they
were already suppressing not only the
conservatives they were already
suppressing the duly elected sitting
president before January 6th so when
when they banned Trump that represents a
major
transformation of the political order I
write about this actually in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds which makes a fabulous Christmas
present hello thank you very much thank
you for my bill but
I I I don't think anything that happened
on January 6th would justify these
Silicon Valley oligarchs kicking the
president out but even if you are
inclined to think that it would
it was happening before January 6th
it was happening just because they did
not like the cut of the man's jib okay
they were already taking this power any
any piffle you hear about John Yuri
sixth it was just an excuse made up
after the fact to justify behavior that
they were already engaging in
then as the election approach senior
Twitter resacs Under Pressure possibly
from federal agencies uh tried to figure
out what these rules are and they
started speaking of violations as
pretexts to do what they already wanted
to do so they were openly talking about
this and they were coordinating with
federal agencies which was not totally
clear in the first part of the Twitter
file release and the reason for that is
the former top lawyer for the FBI was
the one who was vetting the documents
for Twitter because he was working at
Twitter without Elon Musk even knowing
about it
we know that Twitter met regularly with
those agencies
we know that they were meeting with the
agencies about Donald Trump so this is
during the Trump Administration a lot of
people have said well if you're upset
with how the government was interacting
with Twitter during the before the 2020
election who controlled the government
that's Trump's fault no that's the whole
point that's the whole point of the
Trump election even after Trump won he
wasn't really controlling the government
because there's something called The
Deep State the permanent government the
bureaucracy that was undermining Trump
at every single turn that that illegally
certainly illegitimately spied on him
but I think I think it's fair to say
illegally they had they had a false
pretext that they knew was false to spy
on Trump when he was a candidate and
then they continued that operation while
he was president to undermine his whole
Administration they were making up
election rules and content rules and
decisions on the Fly yoel Roth the head
of Twitter safety met weekly with the
FBI and the DHS he also met with the
office Office of the Director of
National Intelligence absolute top of
the spot AI pyramid
and and even even these sorts of
warnings in one example Twitter
employees prepared to slap a mail-in
voting is safe warning uh to to label a
trump tweet about a postal scrub in Ohio
Trump said hey there's this crazy thing
going on with the mail-in voting and
they were about to say fact check 10 000
pinocchios false the elections mail-in
elections are totally safe except they
ran into this problem which is that they
found out that what Trump was talking
about actually did occur and the Tweet
was factually accurate they said ah darn
we've got definitive proof that what
Trump is saying is right I guess we
can't I guess we can't slap the fake
news label on this one next time we'll
get them next time when the evidence is
less clear and so Twitter was lying
government was lying that we kind of
come to expect
but to me the the most
frustrating part of this
is that the preening
holier than thou sanctimonious liberal
media
was lying through their teeth too
I've got some Outlets here
we've got some some news articles from
some Outlets
who seem to have been proven wrong about
Shadow Banning
and Twitter's attitude toward
Republicans
buy the Twitter file releases we have
got
uh
the New York Times here we go New York
Times what is a shadow ban and is
Twitter doing it to Republican accounts
is [ __ ] Twitter Shadow Banning
Republicans no it is not
says correspondent Liam stack
they mocked the Republicans but no it is
not that's great turns out New York
Times totally wrong about that what else
do we have we've got ABC Twitter denies
conservative Shadow Banning claims but
Alters search function so you got to
give ABC some credit here they are still
amplifying Twitter's denial of this but
they're at least saying well look there
were there were clearly some changes so
they were downplaying it uh still very
very dishonest but even ABC basically
admitted okay we can't say that there's
nothing going on here there's obviously
something going on then we've got the
verge
why Twitter should ignore the phony
outrage over Shadow Banning Twitter's
effort to clean up search results is a
good thing
and so the Verge I like how they have
that in the subheader there they're
making kind of a different argument
they're not saying Twitter isn't shadow
of any Republicans exactly they're just
saying it's really good when Twitter
does Shadow banned Republicans they say
let's be clear the argument that Twitter
is systematically disadvantaged
conservative voices can only be made in
bad faith just as the argument that
Facebook systematically uh
systematically disadvantages
conservative voices can only be made in
bad faith that is not true Twitter and
Facebook were both systematically doing
that those arguments remaining good
faith we've got absolute proof positive
at both places The Verge big fat Liars
then we've got CNN here's CNN how
Twitter's algorithm is amplifying
Extreme political rhetoric and Oliver
Darcy writing for CNN says there is some
irony to the amplification of these
right-wing voices Trump and other
prominent Republicans have long accused
Twitter of Shadow Banning users with
conservative viewpoints and accusation
Twitter is strongly denied in reality
not only is Twitter Twitter not Shadow
Banning these right-wing personalities
for their political viewpoints the
platform's algorithm is actually
amplifying some of their tweets to
audiences who do not even follow their
accounts that reporting from CNN Oliver
Darcy total lie complete fake News Made
Up
and then we've got my favorite
this is my favorite one is Brian Feldman
a New York Magazine headline
Twitter is not Shadow Banning
Republicans what does he say what does
this journal say
Twitter's technology for minimizing
accounts instead of banning them just
isn't very good that's a and he was
quoting one of the explanations of this
and he says that's a more likely
scenario than a cabal of secretive
Twitter employees trying to suppress the
speech of Donald Trump Jr's spokesperson
is it bad sure the way a hangnail is bad
but it's not censorship and it's
certainly not Shadow Banning
yes it is
yes it is and so I I called this guy out
Brian Feldman I said hey Brian Feldman
are you going to update your report
now that Elon Musk and the Twitter files
release has proven that your reporting
was just completely wrong
and you can tell that other people were
sending this to him because he was
getting very angry he changed his
Twitter bio too thanks for sending me a
screenshot of that article that remains
so that Still Remains correct yeah maybe
there was a headline that was a little
sensationalist but the reporting remains
correct no you just heard it the
reporting was wrong
the reporting says Twitter's not
censoring it's not Shadow Banning
there's no cabal of secretive Twitter
employees trying to suppress the speech
of these conservatives there was we know
that now we know that that small cabal
involved Vijaya Gadi involved Joel Roth
involved Jack Dorsey in some cases and
but we we know that there was actually a
structure at Twitter in place to create
a small secret of cabal of employees who
were censoring and Shadow Banning
conservatives and who were lying about
doing that in public so it's not just
that the headline was a little a little
hyperbolic this guy's reporting was just
totally wrong
New York Magazine Brian Feldman and so I
tweeted that Adam and you know what his
response was
his response was quote
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna do it right
after I change your diaper
that's what he said this is what the New
York Magazine Journal said in response
to hey are you going to update your
reporting now that this new information
came to light yeah I'm going to do it
right after I change your diaper
that's it this that's what this grown
man
writing for New York Magazine told me
and I'm not surprised
I'm not surprised by that I'm amused by
that
but I'm not but I think other people
might be surprised
say wait you're you're a very serious
journalist you're right for New York
Magazine you you probably were some
neckties you're you're the Intrepid
fourth estate
you're you're the great defender of
democracy which dies in darkness and
you're talking like a four-year-old
I'm gonna do that right after I change
your diaper and I am rubber you are glue
your your mama said is gonna change the
article yeah I mean what I thought that
you no
this is who they are
this is yeah I'm going to do it right
after I change your diaper is exactly
who not only Brian Feldman not only New
York Magazine but all of these guys in
the media are
they just pretend to be dignified they
just pretend to be Fearless pursuers of
the truth
they are
childish hacks they do not care about
the objective truth or speaking truth to
power or anything like that these guys
are the tools of power
they are the megaphones and the
propagandists for
the powerful entrenched interests that
is not only what the corporate media are
today
that's what they have always been
and the libs have fooled themselves
into believing that these journalists
they're so courageous
they're so independent they're they're
not but many conservatives believe that
too many conservatives believe in the
myth of the objective neutral
speak truth to power or news media
that's not real
that's not real at all
and so we in the conservative media I
won't speak for the whole conservative
media but I'll speak for myself at least
I make no pretense about being neutral
on political questions
no one can be neutral on these sorts of
politics no one in public life is
actually neutral on on these questions
and and so given that that's where I'm
coming from I actually frankly spend
more time on this show criticizing
conservatives than I criticize the libs
for
most of the time because yeah we take it
for granted the libs are crazy yeah they
dress up like girls and that's weird
yeah sure but
what can we do about it let's take it a
little further than that instead of just
saying oh did you see that crazy AOC
tweet or something like that we take it
a little bit further because we know
where we're coming from okay if you're
tuning into this show you know my
perspective you know that I'm not not
right right down the middle or anything
like that but nobody is right down the
middle people have opinions okay we're
we're rational creatures even Brian
Feldman is a at least somewhat rational
creature
what the libs do is they just they just
lie they just lie they lie about Twitter
and they lie about their power and they
lie about covid and they lie about the
election and they lie about everything
they lie about everything but the
biggest lie that they tell is about
their own neutrality and their own
courage they have neither of those
things
they're just they're just whiny little
school boys when they get caught and
he's not gonna they're not going to
update any of these articles and they're
just going to move on to the next big
lie
that's what they're gonna do
they're gonna it's in a way I'm sort of
sorry that we're all talking about this
right now because you know they're just
lying about something else right now
and so we're gonna we're gonna be
Vindicated on the LIE they told two
years ago and then we're gonna miss the
lies they're telling right now here well
here's here's one great example of this
NBC News
covering the trade between Russia and
the United States
Russia gives up Brittany Greiner a
basketball lady
who has elicited a lot of sympathy from
the Elites in this country
solely on the basis of her skin color
and her sexual desires because she's a
black lesbian
the the other prisoners Americans being
held by Russia they have not elicited
any sympathy from our Elite ruling class
the Marine the history teacher those
guys can rot according to the media but
Brittany Greiner She's a Lesbian
basketball player allegedly no one's
ever watched a game but she she deserves
the special treatment and so what what
happened the United States gave up the
most notorious arms dealer in the world
Victor boot known as The Merchant of
death
to get her
and
initially NBC News uh had a report on
this
NBC News uh covered the the
story and said
that a senior U.S official told NBC News
the U.S government had sought to have
both Griner and Whalen he's the Marine
released as part of a swap with the
Kremlin but the official said Russia has
treated Weyland differently because he's
an accused spy and that the Kremlin gave
the White House the choice of either not
both but either Griner or wellin or none
that was the first report so the report
from NBC was
Biden could pick do you want the U.S
marine or do you want the basketball
lady who brought the drugs into the
country which one do you want
because we're only going to give you one
of these for Victor Boot and then the
Biden White House chose the basketball
lady because it would win the more
points with their base and with the
social justice left and they'll leave
the Marine to rot
but then NBC News updated the report
so the official said that Russia treated
well and differently because he's
accused of spying that the Kremlin
ultimately gave the White House the
choice of Griner or no one after
different options were proposed
now I love how they they cover
themselves here where they say after
different options were proposed so
presumably one of those options is what
was in the NBC's first report which is
you could get one of either of these
people in exchange for Victor boot but
then they update it and why do they
update the story because the Biden
Administration came out and said no no
we didn't have a choice it's very
important for the Biden Administration
to say we didn't have a choice because
then they won't be blamed for abandoning
this Marine in favor of the pothead
basketball lady
so what what does NBC do does NBC speak
truth to power pushback no Mr President
our our sources tell us that you
actually did have a choice and I know
it's not going to help your political
position but we're going to speak no of
course not they just okay never mind
we'll update the report they did the
same thing over the Paul Pelosi attack
remember that story and that kind of
weird how we were told just what a month
ago
that uh a man broke into the speaker of
the House's home and tried to murder her
and then the president of the United
States gave a whole speech about this
but then details emerged that didn't
quite make sense
and then the story just completely
disappeared and we're not hearing
anything more about it
isn't that kind of weird you know like
if you'd think if someone tried to
assassinate this speaker of the house
that you might hear about that for more
than just a few days before some details
came out that were weird and then it
completely disappeared
well in that story NBC News ran a great
report
well researched put on TV lots of quotes
lots of evidence where they said
yeah the story was weird because the
cops were called to the house and
Paul Pelosi wasn't tied up in some room
you know begging to be released actually
Paul Pelosi answered the door
and then he welcomed the cops in and
then he walked back toward his alleged
attacker and there was there were there
were reports that they were in various
states of undress and then
and they'll and and Paul Pelosi didn't
didn't say that he was being kidnapped
he didn't run into the arms of the cops
the whole thing didn't and then what
happened
after that report which was detailed
meticulous
NBC News
ditched the report buried it online
suspended the reporter because it didn't
it didn't go along with the narrative
that the media were supposed to be
pushing and so the powerful interests
called them presumably
some someone picked up the phone
and NBC News ditched the journalism
as we see here with Brittany Greiner
same Outlet as we see all the time this
is who these people are
you know 2022 was a great year it's been
a fabulous year and it's been a great
year not just for me personally
for daily wire plus we released choosing
death the legacy of Roe v Wade I put Dr
fauci under the microscope in fouchy
unmasked that is to say nothing of what
is a woman incredible movie terror on
the Prairie greatest lie ever sold
Jordan B Peterson's joining our fold so
much more as great as this year was
we have even more in store for next year
and you will see it all if you are a
member if you're already a member thank
you if you're not yet a member now is
the time to join this Christmas season
you can get 30 off new daily wire plus
memberships and gift memberships when
you use code holiday
h-o-l-i-d-a-y at checkout and what that
means is there is only a short time left
to take advantage of our final sale of
2022. go to dailywire.com Knowles use
code holiday at checkout to get 30 off
new daily wire plus memberships that is
dailywire.com
Knowles today
you remember when the liberal media
built up Michael avenatti remember you
remember Michael avenatti he was the
lawyer for Stormy Daniels who is the
porn star who said that she slept with
Trump and then avenatti just appeared on
left-wing cable news ceaselessly
for months and months and months the
Democrats in the news media even talked
about this guy as a potential
presidential candidate
he's Donald Trump's worst nightmare
Michael already joining us once again is
Michael avenatti
says he made his be the savior
something of a folk hero now
I've been saying enough for writing
Michael I've seen you everywhere what do
you have left to say I was wrong brother
you have a lot to say I am just dying to
hear what you think because people all
like you I'm the only person right here
Donald Trump fears more than Robert
Miller we think you guys are the tip of
this beer that's going to take down
Donald Trump Michael avenard is a beast
okay that's true and he's a beast he's a
beast I hand it to her and I hand it to
Michael avenatti but he has a great
bigger calling here that being a lawyer
is minimal compared to what he's doing
compared to what he's doing this man
this man walks on water doesn't he
practically this man he's a saint this
man he's the great hope for America in
the minds of the liberal journalists and
many prominent Democrats Michael
avenatti was a paragon of virtue
so he was just sentenced to 14 years in
prison and Michael avenatti was
sentenced to 14 years in prison for
defrauding many of his clients for
stealing a lot of money from vulnerable
desperate people for being just a
complete
professional dirt bag for being a con
artist a scammer
U.S District Judge James V selner
just sentenced avenatti ordered him to
pay eight million dollars in restitution
to his victims 3.2 million dollars to
the government for taxes that he owes
just to give you a little smattering of
of avenatti
he obviously defrauded Stormy Daniels
that's where we first heard about his
crimes he stole money from Jeffrey
Ernest Johnson Jeffrey Ernest Johnson is
mentally disabled and a paraplegic
he said quote to this day I do not know
why Michael lied and deceived me why he
broke my trust why he broke my heart I
trusted him implicitly I believed the
things he told me but it was all part of
his plan to defraud me of my settlement
to this day I have a hard time trusting
people because of what Michael did and I
live in constant fear being taken
advantage of again particularly given my
physical disability
Dante puts in the pit of Hell
fraudsters
traitors
people who betray those near to them and
who betray their benefactors and who
it's at the very lowest echelons of Hell
much more so than than sins of the flesh
or wrath or anything like that
what this guy did can you imagine you
you defraud a guy who's mentally
handicapped and paraplegic and you say
oh there's an easy mark
and then and then you steal a ton of
money from and many other people that's
just one example
why do I mention this
not just to pile on Michael avenatti I
don't really know Michael avenatti I met
him one time we were both coincidentally
at a restaurant in Beverly Hills and uh
I met him and you know we were sort of
standing at the bar and it was just sort
of generally unpleasant
he wasn't the most Pleasant guy in the
world so I'm not surprised that it
turned out this way but I mentioned this
because you should remember Michael
avenatti the next time the establishment
media
make some Judgment of character okay
when the media come out
and say oh this this Republican this
conservative he's the worst man ever
we're good judges of character he's
there and oh and this Democrat he is the
greatest man that ever walked the Earth
these people are terrible judges of
character
okay these are people who have
consistently built up some of the worst
sleaziest people on earth
and we should remember that I know
they're supposed to be the Intrepid
fourth estate speak truth power pursue
Truth at all costs they're not it's the
opposite Democrats not looking great
right now an amazing turn of events just
took place a Democrat Senator has left
the Democrat Party and it's not Joe
manchin a lot of people thought it might
be Joe manchin because he's often the
more moderate vote who stymies Chuck
schumers and Joe Biden's plans but it
wasn't him it was Kirsten Cinema
who's the other kind of moderate vote
who sometimes stymies Democrats plans
she left she hasn't become a republican
she's become an independent
this is great news and it definitely
weakens the Democrat majority but
it's not as big a deal as some people
are making it out to be and it's clearly
more calculated than some people are
making it out to be because
Hurston Cinema waited to make this
announcement until just after the
Democrats know they they won the Georgia
senate seat so almost immediately after
Raphael Warnock beats Herschel Walker in
Georgia and the Democrats know they've
got a little bit of a buffer in the
Senate that's when Kirsten Cinema leaves
the party had she announced that she was
going to leave the party back when her
leaving the party looked like it could
throw control of the Senate potentially
to Republicans
that would have been huge
so it's not that significant but it's
still somewhat significant okay Kirsten
Cinema looking at her State of Arizona
which is a purple state
is saying I can't really be associated
with the Democrat Party
it's not going to serve me very well to
be associated with them and they're
they're obviously crazy
and they've been crazy to Kirsten Cinema
do you remember when they chased Kirsten
Cinema through an airport and started
screaming at her while she was hiding in
a bathroom stall
trying to use the John and she's she's
traveling and these Maniacs are
screaming at her and filming it in the
bathroom
so she says I don't want any part of
this there are a lot of people like that
you think of a lot of people who were
liberals Elon Musk Joe Rogan uh Bill
Maher a number of other people who were
and still sort of our Libs
who can't be associated with that
anymore
it's easy to get discouraged
as Republicans and that's what the Dems
want but
and they do kind of monkey around with
the elections a fair bit especially in
certain States but the Democrats do not
have a total lock on power okay
the people are still largely opposed to
what they want to do especially when you
look at specific issues like
transgenderism immigration
foreign policy like the people are
largely against what the what the libs
are doing and another little cause for
hope
it was an Iowa State House race
that was just decided
by 11 votes
the Republican beat the Democrat by 11
votes uh this would be Luana stoltenberg
beat out Democrat Craig Cooper
this is not a huge race 5062 votes cast
for Cooper stoltenberg got 11 more votes
at 5073 votes I mention it because the
libs run on discouragement okay the
Liberals have a lot of power I don't
want to downplay that they control the
media they control the education
institutions they control big Tech until
now at least we have Twitter which is
the smallest of the big Tech platforms
of the major ones they control the big
corporations they control the asset
managers though that might sort of be
changing a little bit too they control a
lot they control and now they control
the government
but
they're not omnipotent
and so the libs who have a real
advantage in power the way they augment
that advantage
is by discouraging you and convincing
you that they are totally omnipotent no
reason to vote
no reason to vote no reason to show up
no reason to try to fight back look
they're omnipotent there's and a lot of
people in politics
will by rightly observing the secret
power that their opponents have
they will take it way too far and use it
as a kind of cope to justify their their
lack of action and their lack of courage
and say well there's nothing I can do
the the omnipotence of one's opponent
fallacy and we shouldn't do that 11 11
seats here 11 votes rather to win a seat
there was another race that seems to
have been won by just one vote I went to
the Democrats I'm sure that's going to
be legally challenged one vote I mean
that's absolutely amazing do not be
discouraged the libs the libs might beat
us hope they don't they might be this
but we should not surrender okay I do
not want to surrender I do not want to
go down without a fight
and frankly
if we actually do stand up and we
actually do fight and we actually just
engage in the long hard work of decades
and Decades of taking back power from
and then wielding power against them as
well I adjusted more away of course I
I don't think that they will win
I know I don't I don't think that they
will permanently win let's say that
the rest of the show continues now it is
music Monday
my producers have they promised me a a
song that requires my uh
hip-hop pop music media Mogul
perspective you know I mean I'm Wonder
Mike I've come to say hello to the black
the white the red and around the purple
and yellow but first we've got to head
on over to the member block if you are
not a member click the link in the
description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]